bonsoir à tous comme chaque semaine
france info et l'ina vous offre un
voyage dans le temps à travers les
archives de la télévision pour mieux
comprendre l'actualité contemporaine
vous regardez l'inattendu et vous êtes
les bienvenus la nation bonsoir je
voudrais regarder la franche au fond des
yeux ligne j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils en
apprennent à tricoter colle à votre
place je la ramène à un peu moins et si
vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il vous
manque qu'une seule chose un tout petit
détail le tourmalet valley à mes côtés
géraldine corner lavaud et richard
poirot journaliste à la rédaction dina
bonjour à tous les deux alors vous avez
sélectionné des sujets d'actualité qui
trouve un écho particulier lorsqu'on
observe la manière dont ces thèmes ont
été traités par le passé alors vous
géraldine ce qui vous interpellez c'est
un sondage ifop réalisé dimanche par le
journal du dimanche
et pourquoi donc c'est un sondage où
l'on apprend que 59 % des français n'ont
pas l'intention de se faire vacciner
pour par rapport au vaccin pour contre
le coc vie d'un bien sûr une réticence
qui n'est pas dû à cette maladie au co
vide car les français sont réputés pour
être frileux face au vaccin
d'ailleurs ça m'a fait penser à cette
émission elle date de 1981 c'était une
émission entière consacrée aux vaccins
et aux rapports entre les français et
les vaccins et écouter ce micro trottoir
c'est aujourd'hui les mêmes arguments et
bien moi je suis scandalisée de voir
toutes les réclame qu'on fait à la radio
pour se faire vacciner
dites moi monsieur vous êtes pour ou
contre la vaccination en 20 secondes et
pour quelle raison parce que
si on supprime les causes de maladies il
n'y a pas de raison qui est cause de
vaccination du canton une maladie est ce
que vous savez qu'il ya des gens qui
sont contre la vaccination
je pense que ces gens là c'est idiot
c'est tout à l'heure on ne devrait pas
vraiment et d'autres non voilà la
réticence face au vaccin n'est donc pas
nouveau en france
aujourd'hui on fait exactement ça quand
même paradoxal au pays de pasteur le
père de la vaccination alors autre sujet
dans l'actualité ces derniers jours la
réécriture de l'article 24 ces mêmes ces
dernières heures de la proposition de
loi sécurité globale un projet de la
majorité très controversé contre lequel
des milliers de personnes se sont
élevées c'était le week end dernier les
chats absolument qui ils ont également
défilé contre les violences policières
et cette dénonciation comme on dit elle
ne date pas d'hier
des coups de gueule y en a plein dans
les archives de l'ina et celui qu'on a
retenue qui est notre préférée c'était
le coup de gueule le plus célèbre
c'était au jt c'était donc sur le
plateau en 1981 laure diaz heures de
france 2 cette antenne 2 à l'époque
expliquez moi ce que les policiers foot
dans le dos des arts avec un revolver à
la main et à chaque fois ils tombent
racontez moi pourquoi du manneken raison
moi je suis d'accord le pommeau c'est
qu'il ya pas de raison parce que ça le
problème
enfin il y en a une en fait oui c'est
que les policiers se croit extrêmement
couvert moi je suis pour le principe
rhin de la police je suis pas la
personne ne peut être contre ça sera un
véhicule de dire qu'il faudrait qu'ils
aient pas de police je crois mais je
pense que les policiers devraient pas
devrait d'abord être mieux recruter
parce que vraiment il ya des lots on a
vraiment l'impression d'être attaqué par
une bande de brigands quand on va aux
familles salle vraiment un annonces et
rumeurs laissent entendre et
parapoliciers un carrefour un accident
elle répond sans cadrer le flic est
descendu il disait sa femme appelle les
collègues et tous et ce mec-là se
croient protégés parce que simplement il
est policier
et ça je crois qu'il faut que ça cesse
c'est intéressant ce passage a notamment
sur la fin et sur la formation ce coup
de gueule sur la formation des policiers
puisque aujourd'hui c'est encore une
question qui en débat là le regard de
coluche il ya 40 ans presque jour pour
jour
voilà pour l'actualité cette semaine et
que s'est il passé le 2 décembre à
travers le temps c'est le zapping de
l'ina ça s'est passé à 2 décembre
regarder
bonjour les témoins de ce drame les
survivants de cette effroyable
catastrophe savent à quoi peut
ressembler la fin du monde
toi daniel de ta petite camarade ne te
reste plus que quelques photos
romain gary est mort tout ce qui était
tellement sensible à la tendresse
désespérée de l'auteur des racines du
ciel ou de la promesse de l'aube entre
autres livres pleure un ami qui ça va
leur parler au coeur un beau parler un
franc parler après les panama peppers un
nouveau scandale d'évasion fiscale qui
touche cette fois ci la planète football
dans la tourmente de nombreux joueurs
dont la star du real madrid cristiano
ronaldo l'argent du football serait
caché en irlande en suisse au panama ou
dans des sociétés offshore des îles
vierges britanniques
ce projet cylindrique bon comme ça à peu
près aucun bris et ça ne cadrait pas les
choses et c'est lui personnellement qui
était quelqu'un rouge
intérieurement il est bon sur scène
quand il chante quand il danse là il est
complètement à l'aise son univers c'est
des animaux c'est disneyland et je vois
si notre manifeste pour le mal à 100%
salvatore célibataire de 37 ans vit
toujours chez maman et elle est bien sûr
le modèle à suivre je propose une
culture anti met en avant des femmes
comme ma mère et tant d'autres mères
dans le monde ce soir et à demain
il ya deux semaines les producteurs de
sapins et pousser un immense ouf de
soulagement le gouvernement a bien
autorisé la vente d'arbres de noël
leur commercialisation à d'ailleurs
débuté le 20 novembre
nous aurons donc un sapin pour noël dans
le salon mais savez vous pourquoi
géraldine d'où vient cette tradition est
bien cette tradition elle vient d'alsace
et elle date du moyen-âge donc s'adapte
vraiment pas d'hier pour preuve ces
estampes 1 elle date de 1788 vous allez
nous sortir ces images ne sais pas ce
sont juste des estampes mais regardez on
voit déjà dû des sapins trôner au milieu
du salon ou plus modestement des
branches accrochés au plafond
alors petits points histoire lors de la
guerre de 1870 de nombreux alsaciens
quittent leur région occupée et
emportent avec eux cette tradition de
l'arbre de noël dans le salon ça devient
donc une tradition populaire
regardez cette archive elles datent des
années 60 et on est en provence mais
malheureusement s'il tenait au coeur la
période brésil dans les grandes
réjouissances annuelles aura été celle
de la douleur dans tout le design réussi
dans un coin de la salle à manger et
l'arbre de noël c'est bien mais
compromettre bourse cela le reboisement
de notre région
déjà bien éprouvées par les incendies de
forêt j'allais beaucoup l'eau alors on
le voit sur ces archives les gens aller
en forêt coupé n'importe quel sympa
sapin donc c'était un abattages sauvages
qui est pourtant déjà en 60 ans était
interdite et donc en parallèle pour
essayer de contrer ces abattages la
culture du sapin de noël étaient
encouragés et une région française va
très vite devenir la numéro un de la
production de sa part de noël c'est la
bourgogne en plus précisément le morvan
exemple en 1968 en ce moment vous êtes
un plein boom
c'est en train de ficeler d'expédier des
quantités de sapins de noël
quel est votre rayon d'exportation
premièrement la france et ensuite
l'étranger pays d'afrique noire
l'afrique du sud l'afrique du nord
encore un peu l'amérique et dernièrement
nous avons eu des demandes de moscou or
voilà en moscou l'afrique
déjà dans les années 60 le sapin du
morvan s'exporte à travers le monde et
charlène parler de votre sapin
n'hésitez pas c'est la culture du sapin
nouvelle masse industrialisés 1 c'est
normal on en veut tous s'intensifier
même dans certaines régions avec des
conséquences terribles notamment pour
l'environnement oui on reste toujours
sur le morvan la culture des sapins est
désormais une culture agricole comme une
autre avec évidemment des recours aux
produits phytosanitaires aux hormones
aux engrais des espèces beaucoup plus
résistante qui gardent leurs épines
peut-être c'est ce que vous avez dans
votre salon nathanaël un orgue man sont
apportées alors qu'elle venait du
caucase en france en été ce qu'il chante
le sapin donc c'était de l'épicé de l'ip
serre dont je crois que maintenant ils
forment des nordmann qui sentent aussi
de sa part on va pas débattre la qualité
des sapins toute cette culture en tout
cas grosse demande donc forcément grosse
culture très intensive et dans les
années 2000 et bien scandale une partie
de l'eau du morvan est impropre à la
consommation des pesticides y ont été
retrouvés comme par exemple le
glyphosate est forcément la culture
intensive des sapins de noël est pointé
du doigt une partielle de sapins de noël
en culture depuis des années on y
utilise du glyphosate un des produits
retrouvés dans l'eau l'objectif du
producteur et d'obtenir un sapin de
bonne qualité pour obtenir un sapin de
bonne qualité il faut effectivement que
la concurrence herbacée notamment entre
autres soit le plus faible possible pour
permettre son développement
maintenant et jusqu'à présent aucune
seulement aucune expérience n'a pu
prouver qu'avec toutes les études qui
ont été faites depuis
2000 que le sapin de noël avait été à
l'origine de pollutions aux particules
hier est avérée en février 2002 pourtant
cette étude menée conjointement par le
parc du morvan la drass bourgogne et
l'université a mis en évidence
l'existence d'une relation entre sapins
de noël et pollution alors aujourd'hui
encore en 2020 il y à des accusations
d'utilisation trop intense trop forte de
produits phytosanitaires pour la culture
du sapin de noël dans le morvan morvan
ou quand même un sapin sur quatre est
produit alors peut-être que vous allez
me dire que la solution serait le sapin
en plastique
il est réutilisable donc finalement peut
être plus écolo et bien non détrompez
vous hein parce qu'il faudrait le garder
vingt ans ce sapin en plastique dans son
salon selon une étude canadienne pour
que son bilan carbone deviennent
favorables
d'habitude on le garde plus aux
alentours de 6 ans ça tombe bien mais il
ya d'autres solutions je suis pas très
sympa en plastique en pet alors il ya
une solution
ça serait le sapin bio dont garantis
sans pesticides
mais alors il va bien falloir le
chercher six ans vous en vous en si vous
en voulez un cette année car pour
l'instant ils ne représentent que moins
d'un pour cent de la production
nationale
pour rappel chaque année en france on
abat et on vend entre 5 millions de
sapins pour les fêtes de noël
et merci à vous géraldine pour cette
présentation de noël
[Musique]
autre rendez-vous chambouler cette année
par la crise sanitaire le téléthon
samedi les animations habituellement
prévues dans toute la france n'auront
pas lieu cette année vous devrez vous
mobiliser derrière votre écran de
télévision et sur les réseaux sociaux
bien sûr ce qui ne change pas en
revanche ce sont les trente heures de
direct présentée par sophie davant et
nagui bonjour claude sérillon alors ce
marathon télévisuel vous le connaissez
bien vous l'avez présenté pendant neuf
ans à sortir de 10 ans à partir de 1987
a dès la première édition alors 33 ans
plus tard le téléthon est toujours là
est ce que c'est une bonne loi est ce
que c'est une mauvaise nouvelle c'est
les deux c'est à dire c'est une bonne
nouvelle parce que c'est les français
qui s'en sont emparés au fond quand on
quand on crée cet événement il ya
d'abord peu de gens qui y croient il ya
même beaucoup de gens y compris dans des
journaux de la presse écrite respectable
comme libération ou le monde qui nous
tape dessus parce qu'ils vivent sous
fait pour quoi vous servez de la misère
des enfants
et puis les français s'en sont emparés
et partout dans tous les villages de
france on prépare le téléthon chaque
année donc j'espère que cette année ça
sera pareil alors en 1987 vous étiez
donc oman et du premier téléthon
français diffusés à l'époque sur antenne
2 avec à vos côtés notamment un certain
michel drucker
on va reparler dans un instant mais
d'abord un petit peu d'histoire avec
richard d'où vient cette idée du
téléthon mais l'idée on la doit à un
homme à cet homme c'est jerry lewis donc
humoriste américain acteur réalisateur
qui chaque année faisait un marathon
télévisuel le téléthon le fameux
téléthon organisé en grande pompe
justement pour aider à la recherche
contre les myopathies comment est née
cette idée du téléthon c'est cette venue
du fait d'abord il ya deux hommes
importance et barateau et birembaut
qu'étaient les deux patrons de l'afm qui
était une petite association de familles
et qui comprenait pas pourquoi il n'y
avait pas de recherche qui avait pas de
mobilisation pour pour essayer de se
battre contre les maladies génétiques
surtout les myopathies et notamment la
myopathie des ceintures qui était la
seule qui frappe l plus de gens et donc
birembaut va partir aux etats-unis voir
ce que fait jerry lewis s'était pas
franchement en grande pompe
c'était un studio qui était un peu plus
grand que celui là pas beaucoup plus et
jerry lewis faisait un show tout seul
et il haranguait les américains il y
avait des complices dans la salle il
ordonna des gifles c'était c'était un
gag permanent mais il avait réussi à
créer un événement claude avant de
raconter ce premier téléthon majouri
conviennent avec richard quelques
instants sur e bay justement ce dont
vous parlez est ce qui se passait aux
états unis avec avec jerry lewis c'était
quoi le concept c'est sa-7 vous l'avez
rappelé donc tout et rien donc je peux
pas le rappeler mais effectivement c'est
de bernard barataud qui frappent à la
porte de d'antenne 2 à l'époque on dit
banco et on y va
ce qui est important c'est que le
parrain de cette première édition ce
sera évidemment jerry lewis qui va venir
et on va avoir la dent les images on lui
doit ce moment culte lors du jt de
l'époque à 13h une promotion à sa façon
merci beaucoup c'est votre bille brisure
biberon comment n'oubliez pas le 4
décembre le 5 décembre sur l'antenne de
l'oedt et les marathons
quatrième du nom qui lancera une
nouvelle histoire de la télévision à
paris en asie un clodo broker d'ailleurs
il a été nominé pour 75 miles pour cette
rencontre
c'était un moyen qu'il a débarqué là il
nous a regardés nous connaissez pas de
ses potes un petit peu michel mais pas
beaucoup et nous a pris de haut ces des
artisans locaux des bricolos des
français qu'ils avaient tous et il s'est
un peu fâché le vendredi soir et le
samedi quand il a vu que le compte est
en marche et il est revenu il a fait un
show formidable samedi soir et il était
et après il va revenir une autre fois
plusieurs années après il va revenir une
fois non il a été impressionnant mais
vous rendez compte
grâce à michel drucker on a eu toutes
les stars du monde macartney
michel faisait la présence de lewis a
été déterminante sur ce premier téléthon
je pense oui parce qu'on s'est dit que
c'était pas une affaire française c'est
une affaire mondiale et que la recherche
sur les maladies génétiques ça
nécessitait de tous se mettre en phase
mais encore une fois pas oublier qu'il y
avait une ignorance côté politique que
les chercheurs était très isolé qui
avait pas d'argent pour ça et le grand
mérite de barateau et de mirambeau et de
toute l'équipe et je pense à fardeau
tout vous rendez compte
en temps quand on commence ils nous
disent faut aller à l'école et on va
avec michel et gérard devant jean
dausset prix nobel devant cohen fardeau
au doute et ils nous apprennent l'adn la
génétique et on a passé plusieurs
journées à tenter d'apprendre et de
comprendre ce qu'était ces maladies
génétiques et nous on va retourner avec
richard ce 4 décembre 1996 le jour le 4
décembre 1987
donc c'est jerry lewis jerry lewis en
grande pompe en grande forme pardon et
n'ouvre le vin qui ouvre le bal de ce
premier téléthon français et les débuts
c'est les débuts de 28 heures de direct
pour vous claude sérillon et pour vos
acolytes michel drucker jacques chancel
gérard holtz c'est du jamais vu à
l'époque les moyens techniques engagés
sont colossaux c'est des centaines de
techniciens s'est débrouillé l'ex et des
plateaux jamais vu céder je vais les
défis c'est gratuit l'armée met à
disposition un porte avions
la sncf met à disposition des trains est
à dire tout le monde se mobilise
mais c'est non mais c'est assez
formidable qu'on a vécu et les stars
vous les avez rappelé tutoie tout à
l'heure donc
donc il y avait à douchy de parler de
france via mer de chine barry white non
mireille mathieu gonet c'était c'était
cargèse d'impressionner gérard arrivent
d'un du sport michel bon évidemment
c'était son monde moi je venais de
l'information et je voyais défiler des
stars du monde entier qui venait et qui
demandait rien il venait il faisait un
numéro et repartait et puis on avait
tous les enfants en face de nous c'était
très impressionnant même humainement si
vous voulez moi je pense que quand on
est journaliste c'est très important
d'essayer de se rendre utile aussi à
quelque chose et là tout d'un coup on
avait en face de nous des enfants qui
était en très mauvaise situation dans
des fauteuils et les fauteuils s'était
pas ceux d'aujourd'hui 1
c'était beaucoup plus compliqué des
familles qui vivaient des drames
personnels énorme et donc avec michel et
gérard et on est allé dans ces familles
on a appris aussi ce que c'était et je
crois que ça a été
moi c'est une de mes fiertés le
journaliste c'est que je me dis j'ai été
obligé d'aller voir quelque chose que
j'aurais pas forcément vu si j'étais
resté soit à présenter un journal soit
être juste de reporter quoi au fond on
ne savait pas ce qu'on faisait
on est on a démarré très franchement moi
je me sui 1 bat râteau qui nous dit dans
l'est dans les coulisses des loges de la
maison de la radio
le premier téléthon que jerry lewis
était dans sa loge il nous dit écoutez
si vous faites 30 millions on est en
france
30 40 50 millions ce sera un formidable
pour nous sa peur on a fait 165 millions
on n'a jamais su exactement pourquoi
richard ce premier téléthon c'est un
succès oui c'est des dizaines de
millions de téléspectateurs mais surtout
au niveau de la collecte
donc vous l'avez rappelé par 160
millions le soir même après il ya eu des
165 millions de francs vous l'avez
rappelé c'est l'équivalent on a calculé
c'est l'équivalent aujourd'hui de 41
millions d'euros
oui alors que nagui et sophie font plus
du double
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
c'était tellement inespéré il y avait le
nombre le chiffre de la collecte qui
était affiché sur le fronton et du
plateau du mag à numéros mais oui il y
avait huit cases
il a fallu rajouter une neuvième année à
cannes journée on a mis un carton non
mende était stupéfait alors après les
années qui ont suivi
au départ on a fait 24 heures est encore
dans la nuit où il ya eu deux trois
heures ou combler un petit peu et puis
après on a fait moi je crois je suis je
un jour j'ai fait trente six heures
d'affilée
debout en permanence et on fonctionne
comment sais tu sais quoi c'est le la
décision ni celle en division 2 il y
avait un peu d'alcool un peu d'euros mi
temps et une énergie incroyable que
n'oubliez pas qu'à 5 heures du matin moi
je me souviens que les gens de rungis
m'apporter des plateaux de fruits de mer
et que c'était une fête ça a été aussi
alors moment d'émotion mobilisation
formidable on a mobilisé aussi les
politiques
et puis c'était une une joie qu'est ce
qu'on a
il ya une fraternité une joie qui a été
qu'ils étaient incroyables avec les
enfants avec les familles avec les stars
qui venait on a beaucoup ri mais
beaucoup ri et badauds qui est donc
effectivement donc cette première
édition va se terminer le 5 décembre le
soir et donc le mot de la fin
c'est pour bernard barataud je vous
propose de regarder sa maman très très
fort vraiment je suis extrêmement ému
téléthon c'est un
formidable coupole dans lequel vous avez
tous déposé votre obole vraiment c'est
quelque chose de tout à fait inattendue
mais ce qui est important c'est que ce
soit on a triplé les objectifs et ça ça
me pose un problème énorme je suis un
petit peu accablée par la responsabilité
alors je vais prendre un engagement un
engagement solennel je m'appelle bernard
barataud je suis le président de
l'association et je m'engage dans les
douze mois à publier très clairement ce
que nous avons fait cet argent les
choses doivent être transparents et nous
allons vous les rendre transparents vous
allez voir ce que noah en faire j'aurais
quand même saluer jerry lewis
il ya des larmes là c'est incroyable on
est étonné on a été stupéfait de la
mobilisation des gens et plus les années
passent et plus c'était ça et pas
oublier qu'il y avait pas de gêne et on
n'y a pas de laboratoire et grasse a
effectivement l'afm a été d'une
transparence totale prix cristal la
gestion en argent ils ont créé le
généthon et c'est eux qui ont impulsé
grâce à l'argent des français
l'argent de l'état aussi est arrivé
après après et ça a permis des avancées
incroyables des thérapies géniques et
autres et moi je pense à beaucoup de
professeurs que j'ai rencontré à
l'époque beaucoup de gens qui sont
mobilisés des petites mains les gens
faisaient partout des aînés prenaient
des initiatives pour apporter de
l'argent et c'est encore vrai
aujourd'hui
moi je vois un peu partout je vais en
france pour d'autres raisons
dans tous les villages on prépare le
téléthon je pense c'était tchernia qui
disait que c'était un 14 juillet en
hiver et pierre qui a longtemps été avec
nous donnait une joie une qualité qui
avait beaucoup de dignité dans tout ça
il y avait un respect de la personne
et puis une envie de d'aider les gens
qui étaient dans d'extrême difficulté
il fait partie de notre patrimoine
aujourd'hui ce télé crochet un mot qu un
peu galvaudé parce que en tout le monde
utilise mais je pense que d'abord c'est
l'honneur du service public d'avoir
calais ça je pense que c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut savoir revendiqué moi
je suis très fier d'y avoir participé à
mon niveau et je pense qu'effectivement
ça fait partie des choses qui doivent
nous donner à réfléchir sur à la fois
notre métier de journaliste on est là
pour relater l'actualité pour essayer de
la vérifier pour être le plus rigoureux
possible mais aussi pour savoir
s'engager
je pense que notre engagement de citoyen
doit pas être indépendant de notre vie
de journaliste et je crois que le
téléthon offre cette possibilité aux
journalistes et aux aux animateurs de se
dire tiens voilà je suis utile selon la
chanson de roda gil et de julien clerc
et chars vous aviez une une dernière h
c'est enfin vous l'avez rappelé
effectivement enfin déjà revenir sur des
chiffres parce que c'est une tendance
qu'on voit depuis 1987
vous l'avez rappelé c'est que les gens
donnent après c'était en fait les dons
étaient toujours supérieur à les
collectes étaient supérieurs aux
promesses de dons qu'on voyait lors de
l'émission en 33 ans plus de 2 milliards
d'euros ont été récoltés grâce au
téléthon oui et ça a été efficace
franchement comme vous allez on peut
aller voir le généthon et je crois que
ça aussi donné sur et une impulsion pour
d'autres causes
pour l'association que dès que président
et zidane d'ailleurs et comme sage
leucodystrophies surtout talent la
sclérose en plaques
ça aussi permis à d'autres installations
de voir le jour et d'essayer de toucher
un grand public
je crois que là aussi c'est des fiertés
de d'antenne 2 à l'époque et du service
public
effectivement on voulait finir sur une
archive une archive particulière le
téléthon le sait vous l'avez dit donc ce
sont des heures et des heures de direct
la fatigue parfois et ça donne des
moments cultes et on a celui qui n'a
retenu que vous avez ça vous concerne
claude sérillon vous y participiez
c'était avec l'acteur michel boujenah
oui et c'est en 1989 je vois moi j'ai
été assez malade et quand j'étais petit
j'étais très malheureux ça fait rire
tout était malade petit jeu
[Rires]
j'ai été opérée des deux bras c'est
vraiment si de chirurgie il voit la télé
va dire c'est pas vrai le crois pas
c'est vrai vous en souvenez vous
utilisez sur un quart d'heure parce que
donc là c'était la nuit devait être une
heure et demie du matin à peu près donc
on commence à être un peu sur les nerfs
à tous et puis on me dit qu'on n'avait
pas l'oreillette
il ya un carton me dit bouge n'arrive à
tant mieux vous en arrive et il arrivait
l'émission pull à l'envers il avait les
cheveux comme ça qui commence à me
raconter son histoire donc sur les nerfs
et où on a ri et je me souviens de spyro
de ron stam qui venait dans les cages
face à nous et tout le monde pleurait de
rire
on n'a pas pu s'arrêter et c'est vrai
que c'est culte et avec michel souvent
ce rappel ça avec michel boujenah web et
c'était on a vécu des c'était intense
comme émotion on travaillait pour la vie
pour on essayait de d'apporter une aide
à quelque chose et en même temps on
voulait que ce soit un spectacle de
convivialité de solidarité de générosité
c'est des choses très importantes ça et
ça fait du bien de rire
quoi qu'il arrive claude merci beaucoup
merci de votre présence et de votre
éclairage sur les tons c'est à le
téléthon nous on se quitte avec notre
traditionnel pepita une pépite un petit
peu triste
cette semaine car plein d'émotions et de
souvenirs pour tout le monde anne
sylvestre est décédée elle avait 86 ans
la chanteuse a accompagné des
générations d'enfants avec ses berceuses
comme celle-ci côté j'aime les gens qui
doutent je voudrais qu'on leur foute la
paix de temps en temps et qu'on ne les
malmène jamais quand ils promènent leur
automne au printemps qu'on leur dise que
l'âme fait de plus belle flamme que tout
c'est triste qu est qu on les remercie
qu'on leur dise on leur crient merci
d'avoir vécu
merci pour la tendre eux
ce tant pis pour vous faire
au fait ce que
nous en douter
par là même s'il baisse qui n'a pas
interprété que des berceuses on se
retrouve mercredi prochain à 21h sur le
canal 27 et puis toute la semaine à sur
les réseaux sociaux que ce soit ceux de
l'ina ou de france télévisions merci à
vous et merci aux documentalistes ln2
dont magali vers main qui ont préparé
cette émission bonne semaine
[Musique]